charles berling sera en concert et oui
j'ai bien dit en concert le 19 janvier à
bois d'arcy l'acteur se veut dorénavant
chanteur johanna soudry l'a rencontré et
il nous parle de cette nouvelle carrière
charles berling bonjour bonjour nous
sommes ici à bois d'arcy à la grange la
tramblais où vous allez vous produire
sur scène en chanson française en
janvier que le 19 janvier précisément
alors le public vous connaît en tant que
comédien acteur mais là vous vous
illustrez dans la chanson c'est un peu
surprenant ça
non enfin oui c'est surprenant sans
doute pour les poulets le public mais
disons que moi ça fait le ça fait une
dizaine d'années que j'ai recommencé à
ma passion avec la chanson que je dis
recommencer parce que au fond quand
j'avais entre 14 et 20 ans quand j'ai
commencé ce métier au lycée
dumont-d'urville d'ailleurs à toulon et
bien je faisais du théâtre du cinéma en
faisant des films super vite et de la
chanson donc pour moi c'est je reviens à
quelque chose que que j'avais kim a
fondé depuis le début sans compter que
j'ai écouté beaucoup beaucoup de
chansons françaises que j'aime beaucoup
la chanson française et que c'est pour
moi l'occasion disons de 2,2 au 2 mai
les deux passions la musique et l'art de
raconter des histoires c'est un retour
aux sources et vous êtes mélomanes donc
à j'ai toujours adoré la musique même si
je suis un très beau des élèves musicale
mais pour qu'on me dit ça parce que j'ai
fait du piano j'ai fait de la guitare du
saxophone et que j'ai je pense mal a
pris au départ et donc la chanson me
permet avec ma voix et avec les
musiciens
justement de rattraper un peu ce c'est
ce retard de plutôt de nous réconcilier
mois là avec cet amour un peu chaotique
c'est votre premier album que vous
sortez jeune chanteur vous êtes entouré
de plusieurs de vos amis qui vous ont
aidé dans la composition des morceaux
je fais surtout entouré de bons
musiciens si vous voulez parce que je
pense que
puis on voit là j'ai envie de travailler
avec des bons musiciens dont il ya là
maintenant il ya robert le gall
yvan cassar il ya des gens philippe
jacot des gens formidables dans la
musique qui est qui disons qu'ils ont
aimé le projet et qui aime le projet
équipons que son ensemble sont là quoi
ensuite les compositions directement de
mes paroles parce que j'écris toutes les
paroles c'est ça le jeu ça a commencé
comme ça ne me dit il ya une dizaine
d'années je me suis remis à écrire
beaucoup de paroles de chansons et après
je les ai montré des musiciens qui
semble-t-il est mêlé parole puisqu'ils
ont écrit les musiques dont bertrand
burgalat carla bruni philippe jacot
enfin bien le kent
freddy qu est là et j'en passe et des
meilleurs et enfin bref c'est des
musiciens de d'univers et d'horizons
différents mais mais mais qui sont
rentrés dans le jeu de mettre en musique
ces paroles
quels sont les sonorités jetant qu'on va
retrouver dans cet album j'ai un groupe
de musiciens de composer d'une batterie
d'une base de deux guitares ou bien de
guitare piano parce que philippe jacot
joie la fois du piano et de la guitare
c'est de la chanson française qui est un
peu la pêche quoi voilà c'est ça que
vous en voyez sur scène j'adore
donc moi si je vais sur scène c'est pas
pour m'endormir ou endormir les jambes
l'as aix qu'ils ne
mais en même temps j'aime j'aime quand
justement il ya ce plaisir de la musique
cette cette électricité peut donner un
concert et en même temps qu'on entende
les paroles dont celui d'un peu les
histoires que je raconte
qu'ils sont
je ne
e
qu'ils s'entendent
/
tous
c'est très important pour moi qui ait un
équilibre fort entre texte et musique
c'est à dire que non ce n'est pas
seulement des textes même si j'adore les
tests et je les ai écrit pour raconter
des histoires aux gens que j'espère les
intérêts sera en tout cas pour l'instant
les concerts se passe vraiment très bien
donc ça et c'est ça me met en joie c'est
souvent le public aussi c'est ça que
j'aime bien c'est à dire que c'est la
chanson française c'est un partage avec
les gens alors après quand j'ai la
chance d'avoir vraiment des bons
musiciens qui qui fait qu'il ya la
patate c'est des histoires recommande
plutôt tristes tantôt drôles un petit
peu de tout des histoires de la jeune
russe pas je crois que je crois que
j'écoutais tellement de très belles
chansons mais mais qui qui s'appuie sur
des douleurs qui s'appuie sur quelque
chose mais pour moi vous voyez c'est
comme le film amours de haneke la palme
d'or du dernier festival de cannes
je trouve que les sujets graves mois
mais en tous cas me comble
me me rende positif optimiste dans la
mesure où justement ils sont bien faits
tous les fumées d'un vous suivre à pied
dans la lune
le taux de chair nue au fond terre sans
attendre
et donc je ne craint pas d'aborder des
sujets un peu douloureux même si c'est
un concert n'est ce pas je suis pas en
train de donner ni des leçons de morale
film leçon de gravité à tout le monde
pas du tout du tout du tout donc
j'alterne en fait je suis c'est un peu
comme moi c'est à dire j'aime bien je
suis à la fois quelqu'un de comme tout
le monde je pense qu'il y assez douleur
ses angoisses et ses et qui peut voir la
vie parfois façon un peu noir ou bien
aussi qu' il ya beaucoup d'humour de sur
ce qui lui arrive donc je fais ça dans
mes chansons forcément le but des chants
d'un chansonnier si vous voulez cesser
de faire un travail qui lui ressemble
donc ça me ressemble
quels sont vos inspirations des
inspirations ces scellés tous les grands
de la chanson française de toutes
générations confondues je dirais qu'il
est pour comme ça maintenant mais après
je choisis je veux dire par exemple le
dernier disque de raphaël je les adore
je trouve qu'il écrit à la fois très
bien à pic il ya un mouvement musical
qui me plaît beaucoup
et
j'aime bien les filles comme camille
j'adore ferrer voilà les grands que sont
brassens brel reggiani montant tous ah
bon et en même temps je vis à mon époque
donc si vous voulez je suis j'ai une
culture
j'ai toujours adoré la chanson française
justement dans ce cas-là de musicale et
mais aussi de porter sur mon raconter
une histoire donc là le spectacle que je
fais d'ailleurs il est construit de
c'est une histoire quoi finalement j'ai
trouvé un ordre de chansons qui permet
de tisser quelque chose qui oui qui
raconte je crois quelque chose c'est
important pour vous de retrouver le
public justement dans les concerts c'est
différent d'un album studio qu'on
enregistre seul fondamentale pour moi
c'est fondamental c'est à dire que je je
je parle à l'ag
j'ai deux mois où je vais beaucoup
chanté jeu si fondamental pour moi de
2,2 les concerts le rapport au public
plus encore que faire un album au nom de
je suis un homme de scène
c'est là que ça me quelque chose se
passe avec le public je le sens et ça
c'est important et c'est comme ça que
que la musica devient finalement
je fus jets de fumée sortant
on se fout tout en l'air c'est ça les
répétitions c'est ça tout le travail
au fait il faut équilibrer toutes ses
forces en présence pour que ça soit
harmonieux que ce soit pas quelque chose
de désagréable au contraire que ce soit
quelque chose qui remporte vous avez
répété ici à la grange à tremblay fait
sur plusieurs jours oui on a fait ça qui
est bien là on a eu la chance de répéter
d'avoir une résidence ici pendant avec
des moyens techniques aider des gens
très sympathiques qui nous accueille
donc c'est ça c'est important de pouvoir
se poser dans un endroit et réfléchir le
spectacle donc la salle vous a plu ouais
la salle et les formidables moi qui
dirigeais me sall à toulon qui s'appelle
le théâtre liberté une salle un peu plus
grande 700 places mais mais
elle est bonne la salle aux menaces
allait très bien en plus y'a une bonne
acoustique attendus sous 48 semaines
tous des voleurs
le bayer aux veaux
en jeu
seul
passer sous la
alors qu'est ce que vous pouvez dire aux
gens qu'ils vont pas venir vous voir en
janvier à bois d'arcy
qu'est-ce qu'il est qu'est ce qui les
attend sur scène il attend est super bon
spectacle voilà ce qui les attend non et
des attentions que ceux qui aiment ce
qu'ils aiment la chanson française qui
ont envie de découvrir un jeune chanteur
qui viennent disons que jusqu'à présent
les tous les concerts que j'ai pu faire
les gens sortaient plutôt avec la banane
quoi vous avez pas y répondre et parce
qu'il sape et allemands signe alors non
non mais bien sûr moi je vous écoute et
vous savez je me revendique comme
chanteur je sais que il est normal que
le public me connaissent surtout comme
hunter et donc je conçois que l'on se
dise bon tiens qu'est ce qui se passe
vers les méchantes jusqu'à présent
je vais combattre progressivement jeu
c'est normal d'ailleurs salué ce métier
rien n'est jamais acquis et ses parents
vous deviez choisir aujourd'hui on me
disait vous avez pas
voilà vous devez faire votre choix c'est
soit le théâtre les planches soit la
chanson puisque vous seriez capable de
faire le choix aujourd'hui si vous avez
trois enfants que je vous dis ça sur vos
enfants qu'est ce que vous dites oui
c'est le choix de sophie non c'est
impossible
pourquoi faire ça d'abord je suis
vraiment persuadé je le chope
expérimente tous les jours que ce sont
des harkis sont très cousin et qui sont
très complémentaires c'est à dire que
l'art du théâtre me sers dans la chanson
et la chanson me sers dans le théâtre et
le cinéma dans le théâtre est à dire que
j'ai je pense pas que ce soit des arts
concurrents qui se détruisent les uns
les autres
manitou tout cas et puis je suis
vraiment pas du tout une exception à la
matière vous avez regardé reggiani il a
fait beaucoup de théâtre il a fait d'ici
là il a fait avec ce n'est pas parce
qu'en france quand même on a tendance à
mettre les gens dans des cases je me
suis aperçu oui bon ben je suis ici
comme ça donc j'assume suis très heureux
comme ça puis en plus voilà le dernier
le dernier le vrai juge c'est le public
ça se passe bien mais à vendre à vous
voir alors samedi 19 janvier à 20h30
hissait à la grange de la toile bois
d'arcy
merci beaucoup charles veilleux